[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was so difficult to sport health some
tickets and to see you and now everyone
is going to be able to get their
families together their loved ones and
experience this show and what does that
mean to you all these years later it's
that we we yeah we spend our wheels a
lot on how to get more people into that
show to the point where we were locking
down a block of Broadway every you know
every other day to just perform little
snippets or other ideas just so people
could get close to it this is the the
best way we have figured out thus far
and get people close to it and happening
at a time where you can't see it any
other way the theaters are dark well I
think I think that's it's it's good it's
special and I'm glad people get to see
Lynne said earlier one day more people
will have a chance to see the show than
an entire run of all of the different
companies and on Broadway this entire
time so I mean any time you can amplify
it that way is it's just fantastic no
one else was in the WAV happening
whoever cleaned up
it's pretty special right and I know
this show was shot you knew that this
was going to be the performance that was
filmed did you leave any Easter eggs or
anything did you go a little crazy or do
you just do company as normal this was
really really hard to do really really
really hard to do so you know we filmed
it over three full days in front of two
different audiences and then in between
those days we were able to work on they
were able to get up on stage and do some
Steadicam things without an audience
there but as far as like doing the show
but we were all on the zoom call the
other day and they were like we've
noticed in the inside jokes right
because you know you're doing the thing
and there's a lot of stuff that the
audience can or doesn't see and nobody
could come up with that many of them if
they happened I don't you know I'm not
sure where it would where would have
been but you know we just wanted to get
the show we just wanted to do our best
and like you know do this show so
exciting and daveed I know that you've
said before that you're not a fan of
watching your own performances so are
you having like a huge watch party for
this I haven't seen it yet and I don't
know I'm not sure how I'm gonna do it it
might I might have to watch it once like
very privately like under a blanket like
just really high it'll it I don't know I
don't know I can't feel really good in
it trust you out to know that like on
Disney Plus like hundreds of thousands
of people are already watching at the
same time no I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad
for that it's more about this is amazing
this is a like I also there's something
special to me about the fact that I've
never seen it you know like I'm a
theatre guy like that's the way plays
are supposed to happen to me I never
have to watch myself do that and that is
part of the freedom I enjoy of doing a
play we can I can show up every night
and do some other bad crazy thing that I
never have to be held accountable for so
this this fundamentally changes that
relationship to theater if I watch it
and I just I'm gonna watch it but I'm a
monitor
when I uncomfortable with changing that
relation I love that
well the tagline of the musical is the
story of America
been told by American now what what are
your thoughts on I mean this couldn't be
coming at a better time
in the middle of this long-running
revolution and what a beautiful thing
for people to celebrate because this
musical was so beloved but it also
pushed the boundaries on traditional
theater in so many ways so what you must
be so proud that so many more people are
gonna be able to see it definitely proud
that people are going to see it I think
there's no sleight of hand with this
show there's no there's no trickery the
beautiful part about the way Andy staged
it with with Tommy and and Tommy's
direction and the way it's lit it's
about it actually I think more than
anything incorporates every aspect of
the theater that that you could possibly
put into one piece in that it is about
the people it is about the artists there
are very few props there there are no
huge set changes there's nothing in
there that's going to distract the
audience from the experience of looking
at this looking at this story which
we're all sort of familiar with but
we're meeting it in a very personal way
and so it sits in the strength of
telling the story that particular way
that makes it accessible to people and
it makes it accessible to the theater
goer and to someone who only watches
movies and someone who's never stepped
foot in a theater right I think there's
a lot of converts the you know
conversions to happen because people
sort of view the theater as one sort of
traditional sort of model and this takes
all of the best parts of the things that
we love about theatre and then puts it
all into one package Tommy and and it is
an incredibly incredibly smart and
sincere director and I think that that's
what ultimately the movie captures in a
beautiful way I love that so much indeed
then you're moving on to get together
with Lynn again for the Little Mermaid
so are we going to have all of our
favorite songs we have new
songs like what am I getting oh I'm not
allowed to talk about that I don't know
what Disney told you but they ain't
greenlit me to talk about nothing is not
coming for me like that I have met all
of their lawyers okay I'm good I don't
know nothing about the Little Mermaid
but I love your friendship with Lynne
and probably I would assume it was great
to work with him again
I've gotta work with him again in a
number of different ways and I think you
know the experience is always the same
it's always it was always one of a great
trust from somebody who's really good at
the thing he does to them come to me
with a thing and be like do you that's
very empowering Broadway sort of
returning to the theater what are your
hopes you talk so much about how it is
so fabulous and wonderful and necessary
to be in the theater and see these types
of shows what do you think will change
on Broadway Coast covin I'm I am nervous
about how any sort of theater comes back
from this and I don't know I am it's a
thing I'm sort of in conversations about
a day something like local theaters
because I've only done one Broadway show
so I don't have that connection to that
world as much but theatre is very very
important to me and I don't know how we
gather the same way we did before and
given the overheads of granting it I use
a very complicated some math to figure
out here today I'm not sure how we do it
but I do know that the nature of the
theater is that it adapts to the time
and so it will do that how we see that
reflected on Broadway I am Not sure
because I don't really know how that
works
Chris maybe you have a better idea they
say well I think this is one of those
situations where what is happening for
everyone is truly happening for everyone
um when you can't congregate you can't
congregate if you can't do that safely
and that's before the audience even
comes through the door or like I of
course it's going to come back there's a
reason why we go to theater there's a
reason why the public at large needs
theater it's Church it is it is a
collective focused experience like we it
there's a reason why we go to ball games
there's a reason why we go to concerts
it's a reason why we go to Broadway
shows and you know on its base level
it's not about the thing that they're
experiencing it's about being together
experiencing something crazy take me to
church come on I'm still gonna get on
the corner and and and freestyle that's
I'm saying we'll break if we can't do it
inside we'll take it outside so who has
we have to do but they've been doing
theater long before you have internal
light switch on so we'll figure it out
but it's not really about turning on the
light switch it's about being able to
like safely do that and not put anybody
in dangerous
[Music]